hey there crazies do you ever wonder
we're living in a giant simulation
because I do here at the science asylum
deep philosophical questions are nothing
new
having clones and teleporters around
brings up all sorts of questions but
asking if the universe is a simulation
calls into question our entire existence
the movie 13th floor jumped headfirst
into this madness it's one of the
deepest questions we've ever covered so
let's start a little smaller what kind
of things do we simulate and why Randi
suggested the three-body problem which
takes us back to the days of Isaac
Newton since the invention of Newton's
laws we've been able to make amazingly
accurate predictions about the motions
of the planets and their moons but
there's a problem here Newton's first
and second laws of motion only applied
to one object at a time
the Newton's third law of motion in his
law of gravity only applied to two at a
time that's great if all you're trying
to do is model the Earth's orbit around
the Sun or Pluto and its moon Charon you
just do some math on it and booyah
equations of motion they map out any
planetary path circular elliptical
parabolic hyperbolic including the
Earth's but what if you want to see what
happens to the moon
that's the three-body problem and it's
drastically more complicated so
complicated in fact that in 1887 pocket
RA and Brutus showed it wasn't even
possible to solve equations of motion
are super useful you want to know what
the earth is doing 70 days from now you
just plug in 70 days and bam you've got
your answer you want to know what the
earth is doing 70 thousand years from
now you just plug in 70 thousand years
and bam you've got your answer
but when you've got three objects all
bets are off and things get super weird
here's what the earth and moon's orbit
looks like around the Sun well not
really it's exaggerated this is what it
actually looks like it's almost like the
moon orbits the Sun huh weird anyway if
you've got three objects that are all
comparable in mass then it's hard to
find stability at least until one of
them is thrown away
this problem isn't limited to just
gravity either it's a big problem for
atoms to hydrogen is only two objects so
no problem but helium is three big
problem honestly having only three
objects isn't all that realistic either
the solar system is made up of a star
eight planets and a bunch of moons
asteroids and comets most atoms have a
ton of electrons in them all repelling
each other it's part of why it took us
so long to figure out the periodic table
it's madness so how did you make all
those animations if it's unsolvable I
simulated it with computer code see if
you're good enough with coding you don't
need an equation of motion you just
stepped the laws forward one little
moment after the other if you make your
time steps small enough the animation
looks smooth the downside is if you want
to know where something is and what it's
doing at a certain time you have to wait
for the simulation to get there but
doing things in real time can get real
and practical real fast so you're gonna
want to speed it up a bit and if you max
out your computer there are only two
options one you can make the time step
bigger but you start accumulating errors
over time or two you can get more
processing power either by getting a
better computer or by linking computers
together why are we talking about this
because this is actually how the
universe works even though we sometimes
use math to get equations of motion the
original laws are only defined locally
in space and time meaning the universe
doesn't do any math either it lives in
the moment so if our universe is just a
simulation it must have a time step what
about clock time
that would make clunk time a single
moment in time and clunk length the size
of a 3d pixel or voxel OMG we're living
at a super high res version of Minecraft
[ __ ] you it only have visible
significant and quantum gravity within
this thing yet dang it that would demand
a lot of processing power to about ten
to the hundred and twentieth power
gigahertz give or take which might
explain why particles only have definite
properties when they have to so I don't
know do you think the universe is a
simulation let's have a conversation in
the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy